la médecine avec l'étrange déclaration
du professeur escand dans une interview
à L'Express le professeur escand qui
coordonne le groupe sida de l'hôpital
Cochin affirme que l'épidémie du sida
est pratiquement enrayée alors voilà qui
est bien surprenant lorsqu'on sait que
tous les jours de nouvelles personnes
sont contaminées et que tous les jours
la maladie fait des victimes en France
et dans le monde entier mais pour
Monsieur Escande la prévention et
l'hygiène ont été telles qu'on voit le
bout du tunnel dans cette maladie la
plupart de ses confrères conteste cette
analyse enquête jeandianiel fquier le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que le
professeur escand n'y va pas avec le dos
de la cuillère dans ses déclaration à
notre confrère L'Express pour lui il est
temps de crier au moins partiellement
victoire mais voilà dans la communauté
médicale rares sont ceux qui sont prêts
à entonner le même champ que lui certes
l'épidémie qui devait dévaster le globe
est resté du domaine du fantasme mais en
revanche rien n'est pour autant réglé
avec le sida les spécialistes voient
chaque jour de nouveaux cas de
contamination par le virus HIV
responsable de la maladie même si les
groupes à risque et en particulier les
homosexuels sont aujourd'hui moins
touchés c'est vrai l'information passe
et la prévention fonctionne mais ce
n'est pas pour autant qu'il faut baisser
les bras car le mal est là il reste
encore parmi nous et le négliger serait
catastrophique en tous les cas les
pouvoirs publics ne sont pas très
contents des déclarations du professeur
Escande l'épidémie de sida existe encore
le risque auquel on est exposé si on ne
prend pas des précautions lorsqu'on est
dans une situation à risque existe
encore c'est cela que je retiens et
c'est cela que j'ai envie de redire très
fortement pour éviter toute tentative de
démobilisation qui serait tout à fait
prématurée si l'on veut se convaincre de
la réalité du danger il suffit de
regarder le nombre de cas déclarés à
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
depuis 8 ans des cas qui sont 5 à 10
fois inférieurs à la
réalité et puisque nous parlons de sida
cette brochure qui sera distribuée à 1
million 200000 exemplaires cela
s'intitule sida et travail elle vient
d'être présentée par le ministre du
Travail Jean-Pierre Soisson des
informations sur le sida et surtout
cette affirmation le sida ne doit pas
être traité différemment des autres
maladies dans les milieux professionnels